Steve Byers when is the last time you
guys have all been sort of face to face
like this never like I mean even on the
show I don't think we were this face to
face I mean I guess God it would have
been wrapping up the show really yeah
has anybody if you have you like when
you sort of think about this and
Jennifer I'll I'll bring this to you
right now which is it's odd that it
takes something like all of us sort of
isolating and going through a pandemic
to sort of bring all of you back
together like this you know it's so sad
it is I mean I'm doing the same thing
with my friends every Friday we do a
zoom thing and we haven't connected like
that in a long time so it's good there's
a silver lining right there is and uh
Devon when you think of that sort of day
one onset of Falcon Beach what was what
was that day like for you I feel like I
remember their very first scene actually
and I think I was in a bed crying which
I did a lot of on the show um and it was
Bill directing and I just remember being
like how am i how am I even here um you
know cuz I put myself on tape and I
didn't hear anything and then all of a
sudden was like you're going to win a
big and then I was there so I was just
overjoyed and terrified and uh and
Ephraim good to see you your hair's
looking good now are you getting a
haircut during all of this or no so it
was actually getting pretty long again
but you're within the first week of the
quarantine my fiancee learned how to cut
era YouTube and gave me like one of the
best haircuts I've had in my life um and
I was like two months ago though so I
feel like I might have to like like call
her up to the plate again soon but like
sort of looking like the old sort of
Falcon be chair right now when Melissa
when you found out that you were did
everybody know
would you guys sign up to do a show
called Falcon beats that it was going to
be shot at Winnipeg no no I knew you all
right I guess so
so who was like where did you and I
guess episode Melissa you knew so Peter
where did you think we're in your head
where did you envision this thing being
shot well I'm I'm from Winnipeg so okay
probably Melissa and I knew better than
anyone that Winnipeg was a very unlikely
place to shoot a summer show not that
it's not beautiful in the summer it's
just summer's two and a half hours long
it was fall yes yeah yeah so it was cold
that's right that's right
and Morgan what when you think back at
this time in this show because this was
it was interesting because it was before
social media it was before any of you
know you guys or your characters could
have become memes what was it like to
sort of do this before that because it's
sort of just now it just it just you
have to go looking for it it's not like
you know it's it's not like other shows
now back then you know II I think I was
still printing my sides at my agents
place you know and if you got to self
tape you'd have to go to a studio pay
them whatever it was 50 60 bucks and
they'd make a DVD then they'd FedEx a
DVD to Winnipeg like it was a nightmare
and if you had four self tapes in a week
that's like 200 bucks
right now I do it up my phone I used my
whoever's around to tape me in the stuff
so that that was you know I'm glad we
are where we are now as far as
technology goes that's for sure because
everything's a lot easier and look
everybody had like you I mean everybody
had to be Beachbody ready and it was all
this other stuff back then looking back
now who sort of thinks that they have
and I don't want to use the term because
trust me okay
I don't want to use the term a age the
most but who can least identify with the
character that they played on Falcon
Beach when it go I mean the quarantine
has done enough to the other truthfully
I mean I know that if I may if I had to
get out on a wakeboard or I mean first
of all I wouldn't be allowed I'd either
embarrass my kids or my wife wouldn't
let me so but beyond that yeah I kind of
forgot how much it took out of everybody
I do that physical um but yeah I don't I
can't say that I'd be up to doing
anything I did on the show all day to
get ready for this zoom meeting so that
just goes to show you I would not be
happy in front of a camera in a bikini
anytime ever again what what what are
the things that a Jenner of Jennifer
I'll stick with you what are the things
that you when you think of that time and
you think of that show what are the
things that you sort of miss the most or
you just recognize now how special those
moments were I think the fact that we
were all on location I know that Peter
and the woods are from there but it kind
of made us we kind of it's so cheesy to
say but we didn't have our family or
friends or anything to distract us we
didn't have cell phones to distract us
so we just we hung out all the time
together so we became really really
close friends so that I can't imagine I
don't act anymore but if I was in that
scenario today I feel like it'd be just
I don't know like unless you're jetting
off somewhere and you're you're isolated
like you were so isolated from the rest
of the world that you really got close
so it was really fun
a lot of laughter I thought cards each
of us had car because we were together
all the time we said forget it we'll
just take new cars
that is that's a that's amazing and
debit when you look back on on that time
and you sort of think of you know now
it's not what really so much what did
you what did you learn but do you miss
that sort of sort of freedom that was
part of that time do you miss that being
able to sort of work in that way where
you didn't have the million eyes that
you did as an actor that you do now as
far as being social media and everything
else yeah actually I was thinking that
when when Jen was saying we became so
close because we were there on location
but also you know social media wasn't a
thing at all so it wasn't like you're
constantly on there seeing what everyone
else is doing or posting you know and so
it gave us the chance to bond on a
deeper level and just you know and
there's something about that that is
more liberating that I do miss about
that time and Ephraim did you guys know
when the show was ending that it was
ending or did you sort of say goodbye
one day thinking that you guys were
going to come back and do this again and
then somebody told you that the show
wasn't coming back like how was the
ending for you did you guys get to do a
big goodbye or no oh well we we we kind
of did it but like because we shot we
shot the pilot as like a backdoor pilot
so there was a year between the first
episode and second episode so after the
pilot we said I have fingers crossed
we'll see each other again
then after season one was crossed we'll
see each other again
the season two we said the same thing
probably a bit more optimistic that we
had been pursued and that was in
September and I think I think we you
heard that the chair wasn't evil or
something like that so yeah so it kind
of it came as a bit of a shock there
wasn't really a huge chance for like a
proper but who show of hands right now
who has all episodes on some sort of DVD
or digital copy
[Laughter]
everything she has every article she
knows all about all of you she stopped
you on social media she keeps up he's
all in the car in the front seat right
now who has kids who has kids okay so is
there a point Morgan where you will show
your kids or have you thought about this
where you'll sort of introduce Falcon
Beach to to the kids yeah I mean maybe
when he's a bit older III did a kid show
right before thousand beach called fries
with that and he says I want to watch
young Poppa and he gets a kick out of it
and one of the things that we did was we
guys we've sent you guys to a lot of
cool places I know Jennifer we sent you
to interview Paul Walker do you remember
that I do how was that how was that well
that was weird I'm not like I don't have
your interviewing skills so I was like
okay what do I say but yeah it was kind
of more weird after he passed which was
shocking but ya know it was fun to go to
LA and do and do those things and
represent HEK Canada that was pretty
amazing I always think of that as a
highlight actually is having done that
on your show cuz that was pretty awesome
and Devin and Morgan I remember very
well when you guys went on vacation to
Jamaica to do like this sort of big
announcement for us what do you remember
of that time when we were like oh my god
couple on and off screen like this was
like et sort of like headline news for
us
Devon I mean that was that was a
mind-blowing experience to get that
phone call and be like are you available
to just go ahead and travel to Jamaica
Angelo segment with ET I mean it was it
was so fun to do I mean
we got to tour around the island get a
Butler which was something I probably
won't ever have again you know and and
yeah it was just a really incredible
opportunity yeah and and Morgan what are
your sort of memories of that of it all
have been really fast I remember getting
a call and then being like do you want
to go to Jamaica like Friday or like
okay I mean I was already in Vancouver
with doesn't anyway so it was a it was a
quick decision it was it was fun but we
also became kind of celebrities on the
resort because I guess everyone realized
there's a film crew following us around
so every time we sac yeah yeah it was
fun so hold on hold on a second you two
were like the two individuals that
stereotypically hooked up while doing a
TV show and then you had cameras
following around you like for so many
people that's the tree that's the end
goal are you guys now fans having done
one what are your thoughts on sort of
current teen dramas on either television
or streaming or are you a fan of any of
them I know you guys watched Outer Banks
yet no so Outer Banks explained we just
finished it and it seems like you know I
mean I'm not gonna be so arrogant to say
Falcon Beach paved the way for the show
but man you watch it and you see Devin
crying and there's a Morgan and there's
a Peter and there's a there's a Melissa
there's a like literally it's like they
were all gone posts that they just put
in and moved over and but there's
somebody punching the Morgan oh there's
a Morgan getting punched
you